ja ich werde in diesem Monat zum dritten
Mal geimpft Kriege also die berühmte
Booster Impfung Termin ist gemacht wird
passieren und trotzdem
sage ich hände weg von Sahra Wagenknecht
und Joshua Kimmich die ja nicht geimpft
sind und die im Moment von einem
meinungsterror überzogen werden den ich
für unerträglich halte
ich frage mich woher kommt das warum ist
die Politik so besessen von dem Thema
und warum macht sie das zur Staatsaffäre
mein Eindruck ist
das die pure Existenz der beiden dass
die einfach da sind als bekannte
Persönlichkeiten die sich dem
allgemeinen
Impfzwang indirekter Art wiedersetzen
alleine ihre pure Existenz
zeigt schon dass die Verunglimpfung der
Impfgegner als rechtsradikale Querdenker
Verschwörungstheoretiker unhaltbar ist
das zerstört diese Erzählung die wir
jetzt seit Monaten hören die Ausgrenzung
dieser Menschen und ich finde dass man
den beiden Wagenknecht und Kimmig dafür
sogar dankbar sein muss dass man das
jetzt erkennt dass es jeder erkennen
kann was dahinter steckt und ich fahre
ich bin der Meinung jetzt reicht's es
ist genug passiert es sind weit über 80%
der Deutschen geimpft oder genesen das
ist eine ordentliche Quote jetzt geht es
nur noch um die booster-impfung für die
Eltern und für bestimmte Probleme
Truppen auch im Krankenhaus und Heimen
das muss passieren aber wer sich bis
heute nicht hat impfen lassen der lässt
sich nicht mehr impfen das passiert
nicht mehr und deshalb bin ich der
Meinung
alle die die jetzt immer noch an die
ungeimpften hinreden und sie
niedermachen an der Spitze der Regierung
Sprecher und die
Bundestagspräsidentin und der
unvermeidliche Karl Lauterbach und jetzt
auch noch die Parteispitze der Linken
den muss man sagen haltet die Klappe das
Thema ist erledigt wir müssen dazu
übergehen diese Leute Kollektiv zu
verteidigen denn das wissen wir ja die
freiheit ist immer die Freiheit des
Andersdenkenden so ist es und deswegen
tut unserem Land weniger Hysterie gut
wir erleben eine Aufgeregtheit die auch
zur Spaltung unseres Landes führt und
das kann man gerade an der Debatte sehen
ich fand es wohl tun dass die Kanzlerin
gesagt hat auch der Sportler Kimmich ist
zunächst Bürger dieses Staates das ist
ein gutes Recht zu entscheiden sich
nicht impfen zu lassen ich glaube das
Problem was bei ihm ganz speziell
entstanden ist ist das auch Teilnehmer
einer Impfkampagne ist und ein bisschen
ist es so wie vorhin bei dem Klimagipfel
auch wenn ich natürlich werfe für eine
Idee aber sie selber bei mir sozusagen
außen vorlasse dann kann das sein dass
dann viele zweifeln warum soll ich denn
machen er macht es ja auch nicht erwirbt
zwar bei mir aber eigentlich ist auch
nicht überzeugt und das ist schon mal so
die Idee wer überzeugen will muss auch
selbst ein Stück überzeugt sein dann
fehlt das ein Stück aber es muss jeden
seine eigene Freiheit sein da bin ich
bei Ihnen das zu entscheiden aber wir
müssen als Politik nicht hysterisch
darauf reagieren was sagen jetzt
Wagenknecht oder was sagen andere wir
müssen die Schützen die in Gefahr sind
die sie nicht impfen lassen können weil
die Antikörper nicht gebildet werden
wissen die Schützen die zu alt sind und
so schwach sind deren Immunsystem nicht
mehr die Kraft hat an die Körper zu
bilden da müssen wir uns kümmern deine
Aufgabe machen und deswegen ist eine
Booster impfungskampagne jetzt wichtig
für die die man brauchen die über
70-Jährigen aber es geht ja auch schon
tiefer jetzt ich krieg morgen auch als
ehemaliger Krebspatient meine dritte
Impfung ich bin auch froh drüber weil es
dann wieder ein Impfstatus gibt der mir
sozusagen schützt dass die Antikörper
auch gebildet werden können muss aber
jeder für sich selbst entscheiden und
jeder muss immer ein bisschen mitnehmen
auch wenn er sich nicht impfen lässt
muss er wissen es geht nie um ihn
alleine es geht immer die anderen aber
nicht durch druckstichwort und nicht
durch öffentliche Ächtung wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass Menschen in der
abweichende Meinung haben die auch
äußern absolut dürfen denn das muss in
dem Land selbstverständlich sein ist es
leider nicht
man muss ja fast ketzerisch darauf schon
auch reagieren und sagen 14 Monate mehr
als 14 Monate 18 Monate über 18 Monate
20 Monate haben ja Politiker eigentlich
das Leben von uns ein bis ins Kleinste
müch hinein geregelt und plötzlich steht
da Joshua Kimmich ein erfolgreicher echt
extrem guter Fußballspieler und sagt mir
von euch dass ich mir jetzt gar nicht
sagen was ich eigentlich zu tun habe
dieser Aufschrei den es dann gegeben hat
das war natürlich
symbolisch für das was wir davor erlebt
haben nämlich diese Verliebtheit jedem
zu sagen was Du tun ist und plötzlich
gibt es diesen Kimmich wie kann er denn
nur sich gegen das verwehren also
symbolisch für den Etatismus den wir
erlebt haben für die dominanten Start
der plötzlich gar nicht damit zurecht
kommt dass es sehr sehr populäre
Menschen in diesem Land gibt die gar
nicht unbedingt jeder will jeder
geimpfte muss ich bewusst sein was heute
den ungeimpften passiert passiert ihm
selbst morgen bei einem ganz anderen
Thema wenn das sozusagen dieser
Demokratie üblich wird das große
Mehrheiten kleinere Gruppen ausgrenzen
und
kaltstellen und niedermachen und mit
meinungsterror überziehen dann ist diese
Demokratie gescheitert ja und deswegen
tut das ja gut dass die Debatte gibt
wenn sie nicht hysterisch geführt ja es
ist wichtig dass auch andere Meinung zur
Geltung kommen dass darüber debattiert
wird das Führen wieder und die ganzen
Argumente von Kimmich können ja auch
falsch sein fachlich ich habe gewinnen
kein Virologe will das auch gar nicht
sein will das gar nicht bewerten
vielleicht sind deine Argumente
stichhaltig vielleicht auch nicht aber
er führt eine Debatte darum und wir
müssen akzeptieren dass jemand auch eine
andere Meinung hat abseits des
Mainstreams aber deswegen ist er kein
querdinger sofort kein Nazi als kein
rechtsradikaler sondern Bürger dieses
Staates der eine eigene Meinung hat und
die muss man ihm zugestimmen aber sie
haben vorhin die Kanzlerin gelobt dass
sie souverän regiert habe sie hat aber
erstmal ihren regierungssprecher Steffen
Seibert vorgeschickt der öffentlich
erklärt hat erhoff ein Sinneswandel bei
Herrn Kieme da frage ich mich was geht
das in Regierungssprecher überhaupt an
das ist wirklich die Privatsache von
Herrn Kimmich Kimmich ist ja kein Inhalt
Inhaber eines Pflegeheims der ersten
26-jähriger kerngesunder
durchtrainierter Fußballer der mehrfach
die Woche getestet wird da hätte Herr
Seibert sagen müssen Verzeihung es geht
mich einfach überhaupt nichts an das ist
die Privatsache und Punkt und jetzt will
auch die Bundestagspräsidentin Kaffee
trinken gehen mit Kimmich ich will doch
nicht dass mich die die
Bundestagspräsidentin zum Kaffee zitiert
weil ich mich nicht impfen lasse wo
kommen wir denn da hin haben gesagt die
Politiker nicht einfach es geht uns
jetzt einfach nichts an wir haben allen
das Angebot gemacht das hatten wir
übrigens auch hoch und heilig
versprochen wenn jeder sein Angebot hat
dann fallen alle Regeln das Angebot hat
man natürlich längst kassiert im
Kanzleramt da wollte man nichts von
Wissen und jetzt braucht man weiterhin
auf 2G und 3G obwohl diese Regeln wissen
links widerlegt sind ich habe mir nur
gerade vorgestellt wie sieht das aus
wenn die Bundestagspräsidentin jetzt
geht mir einlädt der sich nicht impfen
lässt auf einen Kaffee dann wird es eine
riesen lange Schlange Herzfehler genau
nein das sieht man auch das geht die
auch nichts an am Ende des Tages das ist
der Punkt dass er jetzt so eine Debatte
auf eine Ebene geführt wird wo sie nicht
hingehört das Staatsbürger der
Staatsbürger Kimmich sein Recht
wahrnimmt sich nicht impfen sie lassen
es seine Sache auch seine Verantwortung
was er mit seinem Umfeld tut wenn der
Leute dabei sind die vielleicht
anfälliger sind für Krankheiten muss er
sich selbst abwägen und die Leute müssen
das abwägen wie sie ihn kontaktieren
aber diese Politik Ebene in Berlin geht
das wirklich nichts an was da
stattfindet es ist an Kimmich
gescheitert die Stigmatisierung von
Abweichlern als rechtsradikale und
Querdenker und Spinner ja die ist hier
gescheitert denn es ist erkennbar der
passt in keine dieser Kategorien das ist
ein junger Mann der eine abweichende
Meinung hat so wie Sarah Wagenknecht
ihre abweichende Meinung hat das ist
zulässig ich bin zu das ist mir dann
wieder durch den Kopf gegangen ich bin
zu Querdenker der muss in Berlin
hingegangen weil ich nicht einfach
übernommen habe was mir da erzählt wurde
dass das lauter das sind also tausende
von Rechtsradikalen haben sie mit
demonstriert oder haben sie mir
angeguckt ich habe nicht demonstriert
ich habe ich bin dahin gegangen und sie
mir anzugucken und da gibt es zwar da
gab es eine nach meiner Wahrnehmung
kleine Minderheit von Rechtsradikalen
unbezweifelbar schon erkennbar an den
Fahnen an den an den Slogans und dann
sonsten war dort ein breiter Querschnitt
von Menschen aus der Bevölkerung da
waren auch Eltern mit ihr mit Kindern
die wegen der der der Schulschließungen
und der kita-schließungen besorgt und
nicht wussten wie sie mit den Kindern
zurechtkommen wollten hier also ein
eigenes Anliegen hatten und völlig in
Ordnung waren